Liu: I'm Stephanie Liu,
and I'm here today
with Leslie Hawthorn
from the open source team.
And, uh, they just
announced something
very exciting last week.
You wanna tell us about it?
Hawthorn: Sure, absolutely,
so, last week we kicked off
the Google Summer of Code
program for 2009--
so this is our fifth year
of running the program,
so it's really exciting
to hit that milestone--
and we started
accepting applications
from open-source projects
who wanted to act as mentors
for various students
throughout the world
to work on their
respective code bases,
and yesterday was also
a really cool day.
We announced the list of
accepted organizations for 2009,
so we'll be working
with 150 free and open-source
software projects,
uh, to mentor
our students this year,
which is pretty groovy.
Liu: Do you wanna tell us
a little bit of a history?
Kinda like behind the program,
and, like, why we do this.
Hawthorn: So, back in 2005,
Larry Page,
one of our co-founders,
was thinking about
kind of an age-old problem,
which is, you know,
students go to school,
they work really, really hard
during the term,
and then over the summer,
they go off
and do various assorted things,
and, you know, what happens?
Their--their knowledge
of their discipline atrophies.
And, you know,
he was thinking particularly
in terms of computer science,
right,
and looking at sort of the--
the experience levels
of different folks who are
coming in through Google
and also what he was hearing
from other folks in industry,
and finding, you know, a lot
of computer science graduates
weren't--or students weren't
actually able to find jobs
in computer science
or technical fields
during their summer holidays.
And, you know, hey, here's--
here you go,
here's open source, right?
Open source
is completely distributed,
you can work on it from,
you know,
the comfort
of your own living room
or your local internet cafe,
uh, it doesn't require
a specific job opening
uh, to be available
to you, but, hey,
if Google provides stipends
to these students
who are working
on open source projects,
they have kind of
an "ex-ternship"
in their chosen field,
and they get the opportunity
not only to have a job
in a technical field,
but to learn about real-world
software development scenarios,
right, so things like
using version control,
or working in a distributed team
where, you know,
some of the developers
are in, say, London,
and some in Beijing,
and some in Sydney.
Liu: That's definitely
important at Google,
with distributed teams.
Hawthorn: Oh, yeah.
Liu: It's much more challenging
than you would think at first.
Hawthorn: Um, so, the thing
I tell students
who are looking
to apply to the program
is, uh, number one,
don't be intimidated.
Um, I hear over
and over and over again
that, you know, folks are--
you know,
they think Summer of Code
is exciting,
they really like the idea
of participating in open source,
you know, but they're just--
they're scared to death
because they think
it's really competitive,
and it's really hard to get in,
and they're not smart enough,
or they don't have a, you know,
rigorous enough background,
and, you know,
that's just not the case.
We have a--a wide variety
of projects from a wide variety
of technical disciplines
working with us each year.
Some projects are
looking for people
who have almost no experience
in computer science.
Some of the projects
are looking for forks--
folks who are more advanced
and maybe doing, you know,
post-grad research, for example.
So there's really
something for everybody.
And--and one of my favorite
examples to cite here
is, uh, a gal by the name
of Angela Byron.
She was a student in
the very first Summer of Code,
in 2005, and when
Angie started off
working with the Drupal project,
she had never worked on
an open source project before,
she was a community
college student,
and she took a look at
the Summer of Code and thought,
well, it's for students, right,
so they have to be
looking for beginners,
so this whole open source thing,
you know, I could do it too.
And she got
involved with Drupal.
Now she's one of
the biggest advocates
for the Drupal project,
and, you know,
four-plus years later,
she is the maintainer
for Drupal 7,
which is the latest
release of Drupal,
she's on the board of directors
for the Drupal Association,
so do not be intimidated, even
if you are an absolute beginner,
this is still something that's
completely accessible to you,
and if you're not
an absolute beginner,
again, it's accessible,
you just have to be willing to--
to take a risk,
put it out there and apply.
The worst that you can do
is not get accepted
and continue to be excited
about a particular
open-source project.
Keep working with them,
keep learning more
about their code base,
keep submitting patches
or writing documentation
or doing whatever
really excites you,
and then, you know, who knows
what the future will hold
in terms of your opportunity
to work with that organization
in, like, a future
Summer of Code,
if we do one again,
or to get a job in that
particular field, right?
Liu: So, what--what're the--
let's talk stats a little bit.
Like, how many applicants
do we usually get,
how many people
will actually get accepted?
Hawthorn: So, last year we had
a little over 3,000 applicants.
And we had a total
of about 7,000 applications.
And we actually accepted, uh,
just under 1,200 students.
So, you know, about a third,
uh, of our participants
actually, you know,
joined the program,
so it's competitive,
but it's not as competitive
as a lot of grant programs.
Um, and we do allow students
to apply to multiple
different projects,
so let's say you're
equally excited about, uh,
kernel hacking
and open source games.
So if you wanted to submit
an application to, say,
the Linux Foundation to work on
the kernel, you could do that,
and you can also submit
an application to work with,
say, the Thousand Parsec project
on their turn-based
strategy game.
That's totally cool.
You have up to 20 applications,
so you could submit all 20
to one organization,
or 20 to 20 different ones
if you want to,
but, um, another, you know,
tidbit of advice
for students
who are thinking about, uh,
applying to Summer of Code,
spend your time concentrating on
just a couple of applications,
something that you're
truly passionate about,
something that's
really exciting to you,
because quality
is better than quantity.
We hear that universally
from our mentors,
so again, find your passion,
scratch your own itch,
it's what's--it's what's
exciting and compelling to you.
And that passion and--
and desire to improve things
is really gonna show through
when you're talking
to your potential mentors.
Liu: So, what--what are--
what are mentors,
what are organizations,
and what are we looking for
when we're looking for the--
you know,
looking through
these applications?
Hawthorn: For mentoring--
So, uh, a mentoring organization
is any group
who is working on a free
and open-source software project
or a technology project
that, again,
results in the production
of open source code,
and this is--
I mean, the organizations
that have participated--
both in past years
and this year's--
are working on a hugely wide
variety of--of technical areas.
I mean, you've got folks
who are working on, you know,
media player software,
you have folks who are doing
content management systems
so that you can design,
you know, websites
using their software.
We've got folks
who are working
on the Linux kernel
and kernel drivers,
we've got folks who are
working on, you know,
creating open-source games.
We have folks who
are working on, you know,
open-source CAD and automation
software, we've got--
there's really a little bit
of something
for everybody, right.
And one of the reasons
why we select
so many different
types of projects is
we want students
who, you know,
have a wide variety
of interests to come in
and start participating
in open source development.
Um, in terms of what we look for
in the organizations
that we accept,
there's a whole wide
variety of factors,
and actually, if there are
projects who are interested
in learning more about that,
there's actually a full document
uh, produced on our website
that'll tell you
a little bit more
about our selection criteria,
so if you're interested
in the future,
that would be
a useful resource for you.
So, other advice that I would
give to--to student participants
who wanna get involved
in Summer of Code
and just open source in general,
is do not wait
for Summer of Code to start
to get involved
with an open source project
or to get involved
in open source,
because Summer of Code
kicks off for the year,
and all the folks who were,
uh, you know,
interested
in a particular project
who are really invested
in that community,
they get really, really busy.
And if they've only gotten
to know you in the last week
versus someone who's been
hanging around a long time
and contributing a few patches,
answering questions
on a mailing list,
um, you know, hanging out
in the IRC channel
fielding questions,
they're gonna be that much more
likely to want to accept
that particular person,
and it's not necessarily because
they have prior open source
experience or that they have
more knowledge
about the project, exactly,
it's more about
they've already seen
that that person
is willing to make
an investment in the community.
There are so many good stories.
Um...
Liu: I like stories.
Hawthorn: I know,
I like stories too.
Well, okay, so...
Okay, I just wanna be--
go on record as saying
I hate this part
'cause I always feel like
every single one
of our students who finishes
is their own success story,
and unfortunately, like,
now we've got, you know,
2,400 students
who've completed the program,
and I-I-I think I know maybe
350 of the success stories.
I really should know them all.
Um, so, a couple of really cool
ones, like, uh, you know,
I've already mentioned
Angie's story.
Uh, we have a gal
by the name of Joanna Trinidad
who is, uh--who is in Brazil,
and she worked
with the Globus Alliance.
They're a group of folks
who are working
on computing technologies.
She worked on some
single sign-on software
for them last year,
and as a result of her
Summer of Code project,
she was invited to be
a visiting researcher
at the University of Illinois,
Urbana-Champaign.
So--And we hear from students
all the time, you know,
"I got my dream job because
of being in Summer of Code,"
or, "I was hired
to work at this, uh,
"software consultancy shop
"because of my
Summer of Code project,
"and it was
my mentor's business,
and I did so well
that he wants to hire me."
Um, so, there's lots
of cool stuff like that.
You know, other cool stuff
like you may have seen, um--
I'm sure everyone's
seen the Matrix movies--
um, one of our
Summer of Code students--
Liu: Oh, that little thing?
Hawthorn: Yeah, you know.
Um, take the red pill, man.
Uh, one of our students,
Adriato Montero Marquez,
one year he did a whole
graphical user interface
front end
for Nmap Security Scanner
that was in The Matrix.
So, I think one of the coolest
projects right now
that I'm thinking about
for Summer of Code
is actually Melange.
And Melange is the code base
that's going to run
the Summer of Code program
from here on out.
And it's the first open-source
project that was developed
at Google, in the open,
with community input
from commit number one.
And it was a result
of a couple of things.
One, you know,
we've got a community
of over 2,500 mentors
and 2,400 student participants
from past years.
And, you know, clearly,
that's gonna be more people
than Google is ever
gonna be able to devote
to doing engineering work
for Summer of Code, right?
And also, we've had people
come to us over and over again,
saying, "Hey, we love
Summer of Code,
"we love the model,
"we wanna do our own
Summer of Code-like program.
Can we use
your infrastructure?"
And since the infrastructure
was all tied
into Google
back-end technologies,
we were unable to do that.
But now, anybody can
take this code, run with it,
plug it into whatever
database back-end they want.
Um, our instance is running on
Google App Engine, for example.
And, you know,
make this program their own,
make this model their own.
And a lot of folks
have already done that.
Right, we've got, like, uh...
The Finnish folks
have done a Summer of Code.
We had, uh, a New Zealand
Summer of Code.
There was a, um,
Season of Usability
for students to work
on usability issues
in open source software.
Like, the Gnome folks last year
did an accessibility outreach
Summer of Code-like thing.
So, you know, we're watching
this meme spread,
and now I've--I'm really excited
about the fact that
not only is the model spreading,
but now we're actually able
to provide to the community
an infrastructure
to grow that model, and to--
you know, to make it
happen on your own.
So that's really,
really groovy.
Liu: That's really cool.
Hawthorn: And even cooler--
Not that I'm not, you know,
totally biased
and excited about this--
Is the, uh--the committer team
for the Melange project--
We actually handed over
project management, uh,
to the community
back in January,
and our project leader
is actually
a former Summer of Code student.
Uh, Pawel Solyga, so he was
a Summer of Code student
for two years, then he went on
to become a mentor
for, uh,
the Natural User Interface Group
in 2008, and now in 2009,
he's, you know--
he's the project lead
for the infrastructure
that's actually
making the program happen.
Please visit
code.google.com/soc
for Summer of Code.
And, if you would like
regular program updates,
um, but you're not necessarily
ready to apply
for Summer of Code just yet,
you can check out
all the news you can use
on, uh,
the Google Open Source Blog,
which is
google-opensource.blogspot.com
So come on over,
hang out on our blog,
feel the love with us,
it's a beautiful thing.
Liu: Cool. Thanks, Leslie.
Hawthorn: Thank you.